salut on est le vendredi
vendredi 20 janvier 2017 dans 59 minutes
et quelques secondes
donald trump deviendra le 45e président
des états unis
succédant ça vous le savez à barack
obama aujourd'hui ça va être un petit
peu moins de la déconne je moi vous
raconter des choses plus décalé voilà
c'est un petit peu plus sérieux mais je
pense que c'est quelque chose des pères
important et ça peut être un tournant
dans l'histoire donc lâché aujourd'hui
voilà je me sens concernée et j'ai aussi
envie d'en parler avec mes modestes
connaissance et voilà mais c'est un
sujet qui me tient énormément à coeur
tout quand on sait à quel point donald
trump est un homme qui peut clivé
d'ailleurs il a été élu là dessus c'est
sûr qu'à la base l'homme
je ne porte pas particulièrement dans
mon coeur c'est pas quelqu'un qui
j'aurais donné mon vote et en qui
gênerait la confiance maintenant voilà
c'est pas demain qu'ils votent cheveux
américain il a été élu président des
états unis maintenant c'est comme ça
c'est un fait maintenant je suis quand
même très très inquiet par rapport à la
tournure peuvent prendre les choses
surtout quand on voit les quelques
signes qu'envoie donald trump je trouve
qu'il envoie des signes tels qu'ils sont
relativement négatif est pour l'instant
j'ai pas particulièrement relevé de
signe positif et ça ça m'inquiète
en tant que citoyen du monde je vous la
fais très court donald trump 70 ans 3,7
milliards de dollars de fortune
personnelle
à 70 ans le mec il est gabas il s'est
super bien se vendre
il a une image qui est extrêmement bien
bossé mais malgré tout ça donald trump
celle qui me fait peur de par son côté
excessif son côté où il s'emporte dans
l'impression des fois les choses sont
balancés à l'emporte-pièce sans aucune
réflexion derrière alors je suis pas
américain c'est pas tant pour la
politique intérieure du pays mais plus
pour la politique extérieure alors je
suis pas un expert en géopolitique
mais malgré tout je suis inquiète je
suis inquiet par ces petites phrases et
par les répercussions que ça peut avoir
dans notre vie à nous tous les jours ici
en france mais partout dans le monde
tremble me semble déjà extrêmement fermé
et vouloir refermer les états unis sur
eux mêmes
mais au-delà de ça prendre le risque de
ce2
déconstruire ce qui a été fait on voit
déjà par exemple qu'il a annoncé qu'il
ne serait pas content qu'une sortie de
l'otan ça va avoir une répercussion
énorme ça va fragiliser forcément
extrême énormément de pays il a dit que
le royaume uni a bien fait de prendre
son indépendance et de sortir l'europe
donald trump continue de rajouter des
couches et fragilise toujours plus
l'europe et en fragilisant l'europe
j'ai peur qu'ils fragilisent nos
systèmes mais tout aussi imparfait
soit-il nos systèmes et nos démocraties
et ça ça m'inquiète énormément
on va très bien qu'il a dit qu'il était
prêt lui à discuter avec le royaume uni
et à nouer des accords commerciaux avec
eux ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que par cette phrase il va
inciter tous les pays qui veulent avoir
des désaccords indépendant et
privilégier les états unis à s'émanciper
de l'europe pour avoir une discussion
directement que les états unis mais il
est très clair que cette discussion sera
pas d'égal à égal
tu vas pas échanger avec les états unis
s'étaient tous seuls de la même manière
que si tu le fais en étant européen déjà
qu'on sait très bien qu'avec le taffetas
les accords n'étaient pas nécessairement
ego pas très équilibré et si trump
arrive un peu à détricoter l'europe pour
aller négocier individuellement avec
chaque pays il va avoir une force de
frappe qu'il n'avait plus depuis
extrêmement longtemps et je sais même
pas s'ils ont déjà eu cette force de
frappe
après j'ai peur que les américains en
eux mêmes soient extrêmement déçu parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui était quand même
élu sur des promesses fortes en clivant
énormément et je suis pas persuadé
qu'une fois arrivé au pouvoir
toutes ces choses là ils puissent les
faire du moins dans la mesure où ils les
annonces et construire un mur sur la
frontière mexicaine faire payer le
mexique
il annonce énormément de choses alors
effectivement les gens les gens
extrêmement pauvres aux états unis
espèrent énormément mais qu'est-ce qui
se passera si ce mec là n'arrivent pas à
les contenter
parce que au bout d'un moment il va pas
réussir à rendre le pays plus équitable
c'est un gros business man
c'est un énorme capitaliste je vois pas
pourquoi est ce qu'ils valent et
maintenant qu'il est lu s'intéresser aux
petites lampes 1 au fin fond de sa
campagne qui
de rien et comment il va lui apporter
les ressources et comment il va relancer
l'économie dans des zones désertées ça
me semble très compliqué et ces gens là
vont être très déçus alors qu'est-ce qui
se passera au bout des quatre ans de
mandat quand ils seront déçus et que
trump n'aura pas réussi à tenir ses
promesses
eh bien ces gens là soient vous avez un
camp à un candidat qui entre en plus
extrêmes soit ça peut aussi conduire à
un effondrement d'une partie de la
classe politique américaines à prévoir
ça je suis pas du tout spécialiste là
dessus mais en tout cas c'est quelque
chose qui me fait quand même
relativement peur on dit toujours qu'il
faut pas juger l'homme mais excuse moi
l'homme à des propos infâmes vis-à-vis
des femmes il est dégradant vis-à-vis de
la position de la femme
alors ce mec là il est quand même à la
tête de la première puissance mondiale
tu te rends compte que le mec qui a le
plus de pouvoir sur la planète tient des
propos infamants vis-à-vis des femmes
ça c'est vraiment problématique il a été
élevé dans la culture de la réussite
le winner citepa le winner et un loser
il n'y a pas d'intermédiaire
si tu étais pas battus pour réussir tu
es un as tu un looser et c'est ça sa
culture à ce mec
donc qu'est-ce qui va penser du clan pin
américain au fin fond de sa cambrousse
cas pas une tune qui galèrent cas pas de
job il va pas penser que ce n'est que là
il n'a pas de chance et qui va l'aider
il a pensé que ce mec-là est un looser
alors qu'est ce qu'il a fait pour les
losers sauf que je rappelle que ces
losers là sont ses électeurs et son ses
plus fervents supporters
il ya autre chose qui me dérange
énormément chez ce mec c'est la place
des médias comment ils traquent les
médias à peine arrivé au pouvoir il
maltraite les médias il contribue à
donner une image nauséabonde des médias
à dire que les médias donnent des
fausses informations qui maquille la
vérité est qu'en gros il serait là pour
déstabiliser le pouvoir
je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya pas des jeux de
pouvoir mais malgré tout c'est quand
même compliqué de crier à la face du
monde parce que qu'est ce que vont faire
les gens après ils vont pas se dire je
vais faire une analyse je vais prendre
les différents médias je vais regarder
regarder leur histoire regardez les
partis prêts qu'ils ont pu avoir et
faire un petit peu une analyse critique
avec du recul
non qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire ils vont
englober dire vous les médias vous êtes
des [ __ ] vous nous vanter et c'est
comme ça qu'on déstabilise aussi un pays
qu on déstabilise une démocratie ne peut
pas museler la presse mais ce qu'il fait
c'est exactement la même chose il ne les
musel pas directement par contre il
discrédite du coup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes aux états unis
donneront beaucoup moins
leur attention et leur crédibilité à ces
journaux l'as et puis franchement
comment passer après obama
obama ça reste quand même le chef d'état
classe le premier afro américain à
accéder au pouvoir suprême à la maison
blanche le premier noir à la maison
blanche
y'a pas mieux comme symbole c'est génial
et franchement avec michelle obama
ils sont un groupe fantastique une
classe extraordinaire la classe à dallas
la classe internationale même george
abitbol pouvait pas rêver mieux
et au lieu de ça tu vas avoir donald
trump et melania alors bon melania elle
relève un peu la sauce mais bon c'est
pas la classe quoi
tu passes un peu de couple idéal d'un
couple qui te fait rêver
un couple de comptes de fin et là tu te
retrouves huit ans après avec quoi avec
un vieux milliardaire américain avec une
espèce de chevelure
blonde platine dégueulasse avec une meuf
qui a peut-être 40 ans de moins que lui
excuse moi c'est pas la classe ça fait
pas rêver
ce mec là il va détruire énormément de
choses et je suis pas sûr qu'ils sortent
les états unis de la torpeur je suis pas
sûr qu'il est ce pays et au contraire
j'ai peur qu'ils fassent tous la verse
donc voilà aujourd'hui j'avais besoin de
parler de ça j'estime que c'est un sujet
important
je parle de beaucoup de sujets avec
beaucoup de légèreté je rigole
énormément j'étais tourne beaucoup de
choses j'aime bien marré autour des
couples autour de la vie de notre vie
des hommes
mais ça c'est un sujet qui est très très
important je sais pas ce que tu en
penses
je sais pas toi quelle est ton opinion
peut-être que tu penses pas du tout
comme moi peut-être que pour toi trump
c'est un mec qui a réussi à dire la
vérité et qui a fait les choses que
d'autres n'ont pas fait mais tu sais moi
ça me fait extrêmement peur parce que
dans quelques mois il ya l'élection
présidentielle en france
on sort quand même d'un quinquennat très
compliqué aujourd'hui les enjeux pour le
monde sont plus que jamais important
on est quand même à une frontière très
très minces de voir péter des systèmes
de voir péter des démocraties
ça reste très compliqué donc je pense
qu'il faut s'intéresser à ces sujets qui
font discuter on a le droit pas d'accord
il faut se respecter il faut en discuter
voilà donc c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
je me suis permis d'aller sur un sujet
un peu plus sérieux j'espère ne pas
t'avoir sous les sites est arrivé jusque
là regardez la vidéo
jusqu'à ce moment là c'est que malgré
tout ça fait mouche merci d'avoir écouté
merci d'avoir été là
si tu aimes abonne toi laisse moi un
commentaire on discute de tout ça parce
que je pense que voilà moi je suis en
train de faire un monologue face à une
caméra
même si je sais que c'est toi que je
parle au fond de la salle mais voilà
c'est toujours bien d'avoir cette
interaction et d'avoir ton retour donc
laisse-moi des commentaires dis moi ce
que t'en penses et moi je tends branche
sur cnn tout de suite voilà allez c'est
parti mon lapin
singh